sam et moi c'est moi ni semaine d'
enquête a bien sûr monique du jury de
cette caisse qui saurait johnny depp tu
connais même pas chanteur français tu va
nous dire et là elle a fait une audience
catastrophique
elle a eu des avocats qui ont été
ridiculisés par mer sur un lit de la
justice est passée mais ce que vous
voulez de plus bien sûr qu est ce que
vous voyez c'est ça la justice même 65
justice monique j'ai bien de dire que
c'est michel de tous bords non mais
c'est vrai
j'aurais du mal à ses jeunes poulains
refit le début j'ai trouvé l'histoire
elle et elle est victime d'une haine
depuis le début quand même si elle a
menti tout l'audience
que tu connais rien suivi à l'arrière
je n'ai jamais pris l'avion
mais tu connais
andorre toile ne faites pas chier on
encore
s'il vous plaît ce n'est même pas la
massachusetts
que tu connais tu connais rien n'a rien
le toner des centaines de victimes on
sait même pas pourquoi tu es la question
c'est calme toi ça te plaît arrête de
parler
mais tais toi
ce n'est bonne que les quotas devraient
décoller des droits et te fais du val
une j'ai du mal
[Applaudissements]
les noirs sont également candidats
vous dites pourquoi toute beauté /
tirer
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
il est en dépression
kilos
non mais c'est vrai que pardon mais
monique est en train de se fourvoyer
c'est pas parce que je suis en mode
égard aux drogues qui est forcément
coupable a bien sûr l'a dit n'importe
quoi dit que je passe autant
chez tout le monde
le lift et la libération de la parole en
tant que femme ne mérite pas qu'on monte
il a bien sûr fait beaucoup de mal sur
des mois l'annulation de la parole parce
qu'elle a menti sur tout a bien sûr pas
le problème c'est que montano et michel
est ce que vous en dieu couleurs monde
n'a pas compris la france arrête de
marmonner doit-on dans tulle puis de
valeur
[Musique]
mais mon frère de peter
on ne juge pas injuste par sa vie plus
tranquille
diffamation uniquement ça ce qu'il a
fait je ne sais quoi parce que j'ai même
pas ce que c'est qu'un hashtag
si tu sais rien sur rien pourquoi depuis
tout à l'heure tu sais pas c'est sérieux
et adroits to tackle
à peine elle avait ouvert la bouche je
suis désolé c'est un délit de sale
gueule parce que tu es là
il faut que j'en ai une ville lorsque
même sale gueule pour toi n'importe quoi
n'importe où ni quand
ni
croll a fait du bien gymnique